[Music]
that thing does not obey the laws of
physics at all kid there's a lot going
on here that you don't understand stark
said you'd say that wow
he also said to go for your legs
the marvel cinematic universe has
redefined the way viewers approach big
budget movie releases smartly adapting a
philosophy which worked well in the
comics it created a living breathing
world for superheroes to populate meet
up and fight common enemies in it also
created an unprecedented sense of
momentum by constantly teasing the next
big thing a tactic also borrowed from
marvel comics whose story lines crossed
into various titles and while the mcu
may have only existed for roughly half
of rotten tomatoes lifespan it has
created its fair share of memorable
moments so with that in mind we're
counting down the best moments in the
mcu you will never forget
stop
of course narrowing down the list was a
bit of a challenge there are over 20 mcu
films with more coming out every year
most of which are filled with a ton of
memorable moments so we tried to choose
those that were not just memorable but
which also showed how the mcu was
working differently than other
franchises using surprise twists and
scenes that pushed the universe in
different directions and we tried to
share the love among the different
titles i mean there are just too many
moments to choose from that it's hard to
narrow it down so we're strictly
focusing on phases one through three
just to keep things simple phase four
and beyond are sure to have plenty of
moments to talk about so maybe we'll
revisit that one day and we'll be going
over key plot details about nearly every
mcu movie so consider this your official
spoiler warning
i live for the simple things
like how much this is gonna hurt
[Music]
yeah right little man
and just like that with the snap of our
fingers we're ready to count down the
biggest and best moments in the mcu
[Music]
starting with number 10 doctor strange
dormammu bargain
if there is one long-standing criticism
of marvel movies it is their habit of
pitting the heroes against dark mirror
versions of themselves particularly in
their origin movies doctor strange
confronted this critique by having
steven strange lock his ultimate
adversary the trans-dimensional death
cloud dormammu in a time loop and
bargaining with the entity to spare the
earth now that clever and innovative
resolution is one we never stop citing
as an mcu highlight
[Music]
i've come to bargain
illusion
no this is real
i brought a little power from mine
this
is time
endless
looped
time
for mamu i've come to bargain
you cannot do this forever
actually i can
this is how things are now
you and me trapped in this moment
endlessly
captain marvel rises
in a film that reverses the traditional
superhero origin arc carol discovers
that the power was within her all along
casting off the limiter tech that the
cree told her was the source of her
abilities she ignites with power so for
anyone who grew up and were told that
their innate skills were personality
flaws the moment resonates and sets
carol apart as one of the mightiest if
not the mightiest avenger
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
return to the jump point
we'll be back for the weapon
the core
the woman
[Music]
number eight guardians of the galaxy we
are groot
now we've heard gert speak his only
phrase throughout the entire film i am
groot but everyone's favorite talking
tree has a pivotal moment in the final
act of guardians of the galaxy at a
desperate point for the group groot
sacrifices himself to save his friends
and as rocket tries to stop him groot's
vocabulary changes ever so slightly and
if you didn't cry during this part i am
convinced you officially have no soul
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no groot
you can't
you'll die
why are you doing this
why
we
[Music]
number seven the avengers battle of new
york
and yet if there is one most memorable
and most defining moment it is the pan
across a destroyed new york street
revealing the avengers assembled for the
first time in common purpose the entire
film and the five films preceding it
lead up to this moment in which six
superheroes shared the screen and proved
that this crazy idea of an
interconnected latticework of film
franchises could work it also helps that
it is a kick-ass shot uniting the film's
key theme with all the expectations
outside of the narrative the avengers
can work together and so can all these
stars in different interests we wouldn't
be at endgame without this memorable
moment
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
number six avengers age of ultron the
millionaire contest
this marvelous moment shows a different
side of the avengers after winding down
from post hydra defeat party the
avengers gather together with drinks and
a few good laughs when hawkeye questions
the magic behind thor's hammer the
others join in to try and lift the
magical weapon while no one is
successful one avenger comes very close
almost putting thor in a panic a brief
scare sure but we all know who's truly
worthy amongst the avengers crew
never one to shrink from an honest
challenge
it's physics
right so i if i lift it i i then rule
asgard yes of course
i will be reinstituting primonocta
all right
be right back
are you even pulling are you on my team
just represent paul all right let's go
[Music]
come on cap
oh no no that's not a question i need
answered all difference to the man who
wouldn't be king but it's rick you bet
you're
steve he said a bad language word do you
tell everyone about the headless imprint
right like a security code whosoever is
carrying thor's fingerprints is i think
the literal translation yes well that's
uh that's a very very interesting theory
i have a simpler one
you're all not worthy
number five captain america the winter
soldier the elevator fight
now marvel knew they had a winner in
this scene and it featured heavily in
the trailers while the fight is one of
the most accomplished in any of the
marvel movies it continues to resonate
because steve rogers gave the hydra
agents a choice now for all the
impressive battle choreography that
we've seen the scene is still about
steve's inherent sense of goodness and
fair play and that he can survive a
multi-story fall
before we get started
does anyone want to get out
uh
[Music]
[Music]
mobilize strike units 25th floor
[Music]
i just want
it kind of feels personal
number four captain america civil war
airport battle
a good marvel team-up generally sees the
heroes fight among themselves before
joining forces against a common foe and
in the larger mcu infinity saga this is
that moment filled with amazing action
great jokes and peter parker's debut as
the mcu spider-man it is the most
memorable marvel fight yet committed to
screen i mean sure it does bring the
movie to a halt but it is so worth it
just to see peter inadvertently aid
shame the rest of the avengers
[Music]
[Music]
what do we do cam
we fight
this is gonna end well
they're not stopping neither we
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're still friends right spencer
already hit me
you're pulling your punches
i didn't kill your father then why did
you run
[Music]
three black panther killmonger's death
black panther eventually turns
killmonger into a dark mirror version of
t'challa but it does it in the service
of something so powerful raw and
genuinely startling for any film that it
deserves special recognition a defeated
killmonger refuses aid but makes one
request bury me in the ocean with my
ancestors that jump from the ships
because they knew death was better than
bondage now that statement and the
history bursting from it leaves all who
hear it shaken to their core
[Music]
it's beautiful
maybe we can still heal you
why
so you can just lock me up
no
just buried me in the ocean
with my ancestors that jumped from the
ships
because they knew death
was better than bondage
[Music]
number two avengers end game avengers
assemble
at possibly the darkest moment for the
avengers all hope seems lost the
avengers are scattered beneath the
rubble of their base thanos calls for
the rest of his army and standing in his
way is an injured captain america with a
broken shield cap is ready to fight the
army solo until he hears a familiar
voice what follows is hands down one of
the greatest moments in the mcu hundreds
of portals every marvel hero you can
think of and an iconic phrase that kicks
off the final battle with thanos and his
army
[Applause]
[Music]
avengers
assemble
[Music]
so
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
avengers infinity war mr stark i don't
feel so good
every loss in infinity war hits people
differently but none captured the
collective feels of fans quite like
peter's final moment with tony it all
begins with that line and some fans have
theorized his spider sense gave him
early warning about his own demise
making the scene all the more wrenching
upon second viewing additionally it's
the ultimate expression of tony's
failure he spent movies trying to save
the world in general and peter in
particular even when peter inevitably
returns we expect that this scene will
always make people cry
tony
there was no other way
does it start
i don't feel so good
you're all right i don't i don't know
what's happening i don't know okay
i don't want to go i don't want to go
sir please oh you don't want to go
sorry
[Music]
he did it
avengers infinity war she's not alone in
terms of iconic and surprising team-ups
we often think of key male combos like
thor and rocket but infinity war
features a killer battle between proxima
midnight and the combined might of okoye
scarlet witch and black widow all fight
fiercely but it's nat's declaration
she's not alone when proxima first
threatens wanda that keeps this epic
wakanda battle in our minds
he'll die alone as will you
she's not alone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's really gross
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 the
watcher
while all of the late stan lee cameos
are memorable we choose to single out
this goofball volume 2 moment because it
gives all of his scenes a context lee's
appearances throughout the mcu are all
manifestations of a watcher cosmic
entities who literally watch events
unfold across the universe without
interfering it gives each jokey walk-on
an added and heartwarming meaning
oh man anyway before i was so rudely
interrupted at that time i was a federal
express man hey wait where are you going
hey you were supposed to be my left home
how will i get out of here hey oh gee
i've got so many more stories to tell ah
guys oh gee
and finally number one avengers end game
i am iron man
the battle with thanos has nearly ended
and retains the gauntlet with all six
stones attached but the last person in
his way is iron man himself and he
refuses to give up the gauntlet and the
stones after a brief moment with doctor
strange tony finally realizes what he
must do he eventually obtains the stones
and snaps his own fingers turning
thanos's quest against him but before
the snap stark says his final words a
moment that mirrors the ending of the
first iron man film and something we all
will never forget tony stark we love you
three thousand
[Music]
i am
inevitable
and i
and
iron man
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love and
until next time i'm your host naz perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
10s on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you